damit werden hollywood wasser hat
vorjahr
ernsthaft herzlich willkommen in monats
fünf minuten
heute machen wir es ganz ganz besonderes
und zwar mache ich eine torte ja ich
mache am sonntag ist muttertag und
morgen und tag vorher also morgen hat
die mutter von der selic geburtstag als
ein tag vor muttertag hat celles mamas
geburtstag nicht genutzt geburtstag
hatte und deswegen mache ich eine torte
für den endgegner für die mutter meiner
frau also den endgegner
generell kann man jetzt otte und ich
mache was ganz ganz besonderes und zwar
mache ich einen einen mann podkoren ein
wohnpark kuchen ist ein all in one
treibt das ist backen auf geringem
bildungsniveau ihr braucht wie ich mich
wieder für ihr müsst nicht viel
überlegen geht ganz einfach und ich
zeige ich es wie es geht
ok maus riemst alles da dann fangen wir
an mit den grandiosen zutaten wir
brauchen hier vier eier von glücklichen
hühnern einen becher und zwar der becher
hat 250 milliliter wie das haben die
meisten kleinen becher dann brauchen wir
typ core i5 qualitätsweizen mit
horrendem backeigenschaften dann haben
wir südzucker warum süd sogar warum
warum jungs noch mal eine super weil wir
aus dem süden kommen richtig richtig so
dann haben wir hier ein dunkler und von
dem almdudler brauchen wir euch nur ein
glas warum haben wir einen bruder hat es
einen grund ja es hat einen grund und
zwar ich habe vergessen mineralwasser
einzukaufen
normalerweise mit mineralwasser aber
dass der kuchen evas mutter ist ist es
egal wenn die wird es eh nicht merken
dann haben wir hier sonnenblumenöl
reines sonnenblumenöl von den sonnen
dann haben wir hier gar sie joghurt und
zwar 35 prozent fett brauchen wir mehr
gas
wisst ihr das werde dafür bezahlt nicht
egal
trotzdem sah sie drei mal 3,5 prozent er
ist lecker dann haben wir salz eine
prise man den extrakt und eine zitrone
und dann noch backpulver und zwar dieses
back präsentieren was ist besonders an
diesem backpulver es ist eine grosse
verpackung
dann haben wir mit zitronen die zitrone
ist schon abgerissen warum raummangels
wisst ihr warum die zitronen schon
abgeschrieben ist nein weil ich gestern
schon trainiert habe okay dann ist
eigentlich ganz ganz einfach das ist
jeder für dich versteht ist versteht
wirklich jeder auch die männer unter
euch die ich machen konnte
es ist wie ein wort gericht also alles
in einem pott dann fangen wir an mit den
eiern richtig richtig so hier ist es
eigentlich egal welche reihenfolge
könnte man schaue mich hier anfangen mit
dem vierten können die anfangen ich bin
mit 1 anfangen ich möchte jetzt gar
nicht durcheinander bringen können damit
drei anfangen dann ist hoch arbeiten
dann wieder runter also ich kann mit
einer nummer drei wäre es da rein
schlagen die schale ist jetzt ins
reingefallen
das ist kann gefährlich werden warum tom
ist ihr dass jungs wissen dass baum weil
sich die salmonellen immer auf der
schale befinden so ich habe auch schon
mitgedacht ich habe die eier vorher
desinfiziert richtig richtig gut also
aufpassen wenn die wenn die eierschale
reinfeldt dann könnt ihr müsse die eier
noch mal aufschlagen
jetzt noch mal drei was auch vorgehabt
nummer
wieder runter also ich kann mit 1313 ein
kreis nicht mehr werde ich schon
aufgeschlagen
ich gucke was wir hier hier und auf 303
schlagen bis drei träume schal natürlich
gleich wieder auf und arbeiter und wenn
natürlich trotzdem irgendwie salmonellen
daher reingekommen sind nicht schlimm
weil dies für die schwiegermutter
das macht ja nix aus dann haben wir hier
fertig und aufgeräumt wahnsinn jungs
haben es gesehen
merkt euch das bitte jetzt haben wir ein
glas
wir müssen nur ein glas wein spanisch
abspielen ich bin schwabe bin sparsam
deswegen machen wir zuerst die trockenen
zutaten sonst mit lebt das glas richtig
gut aufgepasst so jetzt erst die
trockenen zutaten und zwar ist es ganz
ganz teilnimmt in sydney und es ist so
fein
das ist ein riesen hier haben wir 250
gramm oder 250 milliliter weil
umrechnungsfaktor ich immer 9,7 beim
wasser es ist hohe physik habe ich
gelernt achte klasse der hauptschule
physik leistungskurs so tumor ein
dann nehmen wir den südzucker manche von
euch wären jetzt fragen punkt sind es
auch die nordzucker ja als funktioniert
sogar nur der südzucker ist cooler warum
sage ich das
warum werde ich mit dem geschäftsführer
von südzucker gerne mal golf spielen
gehen
hat loch macht uns aber nichts aus 250
milliliter sogar und jetzt wie gesagt
dass sie trockenen zutaten dann nehme
eine prise salz war es gerade der
postbote war dass gerade der postbote
ich gehe kurzem macht den postboten auf
das war jetzt gerade buddy wir lassen
uns aber nicht von unserem
von unserer reise abbringen jetzt ist
mir eingefallen wir haben nochmal mehr
vergessen es sind zwei fächer mehr
können wir dieses tolle in sydney und
sportstar rein in den becher wo ist der
becher da welcher ist hier hat er sich
versteckt hier 250 milliliter becher
gramm mehl hier ein wahnsinn so hats
gesehen
ich habe darüber gibt es da rein gemacht
das nennt man dann no look also dann
haben wir 250 mineralwasser wie gesagt
wir hatten kein mineralwasser also keine
kohlensäure deswegen wie gesagt es ist
egal wer ist für die schwiegermutter das
interessiert teilen so jetzt hab ich was
vergessen wir machen die kommunen
zutaten ok habe ich eine prise salz
schon rein gemacht noch nicht okay eine
prise salz ist eine prise salz
warum macht man salz in einem süßen
kugeln richtig so
das auge land formiert und dann nehmen
wir einen teelöffel vanille extrakt und
zwar schütteln wir das so jetzt sind die
samen durcheinander
es muss da rein sagt ein teelöffel im
fernsehen sieht es ein bisschen mehr aus
ist aber nur ein teelöffel gelesen so
dann nehmen wir weiter wachsen
backpulver hier ist 18 kam drin weil drk
sind nur wie wir drin weiß es jemand
weiß ist jemand 16
810 gramm und warum machen wir backen
reinweiß es jemand weiß das jemand nein
es geht
backpulver machen wir ein weil es gibt
kraft genau das treibt den teig nach
oben woher weiß ich das weiß das jemand
weiß das jemand warum weil ich mir das
schon mal zugeschaut hat okay dann
nehmen wir eine bio zitrone und zwar
wieder zu rollen wie schon erwähnt habe
ich gestern schon trainiert deswegen ist
das schon alles weg
jetzt wurde ich noch mal hier eine reibe
und jetzt einen kleinen tipp an euch
normalerweise schreibt er ja so ja so
weit mehr
ich schreibe aber nicht so ich hab so
bleibe ich so toll
ja weil ich da bessere kontrolle habe
und keine ahnung hat das ähnlich gesehen
so schreibt es so rein
natürlich ganz ganz wichtig ist eine bio
wie zitronen nehmen und zwar ist die
nicht behandelt
hier seht ihr das und jetzt mach ich das
ding rein jetzt können wir die flüssigen
zutaten hinzugeben und zwar fangen wir
an mit dem mineralwasser oder in dem
fall
warum haben wir einen drüber weiß es
auch jemand weiß dem angebot x 69 cent
ruhigen sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schmecken abschmecken bisschen mehl ich
jetzt weiß ich auch warum es so günstig
war
250 milliliter kämmerei machen
jetzt muss sonnenblumenöl als nächstes
das sonnenblumenöl da machen auch 52
meter ist ein becher 250 milliliter
sonnenblumen man auch daheim und dann
brauchen wir noch schmandt ich habe
keinen mann gefunden also nämlich ein
becher joghurt das gleiche weil beides
weiß ist und das ist kein könnte man
auch joghurt nehmen also nur heute so
wahnsinnig die cremig oder so am band
auch daran dass jetzt nicht schön aus
aber auch schmecken
jetzt räumt erstmal die sauerei weg die
ihr gemacht habe und dann geht es dann
weiter und dann per man es richtig so
ihr habt jetzt gesehen es geht relativ
schnell ein ganz ganz einfach das ist
wirklich jeder hinbekommt was ich jetzt
mache ist
ich habe jetzt alle zutaten hier in
dieser schlag schüssel drin okay warum
schlagschüsse warum weil ich hier drin
schlagen kann
ok habe es verstanden deswegen ist jetzt
eben hier und das ist einfach zusammen
ich brauche dazu keine küchenmaschine
wir sparen uns den strom
ich gucke nur kurz nach einem männlichen
schneebesen haben wir hier aus
edelsteinen dann immer diesen männlichen
schneebesen und schlagen jetzt die masse
zu einer homogenen masse habe ich das
richtig ausgedrückt haben hat er richtig
es hat sich intelligent angehört richtig
wahnsinnig so und jetzt schlage ich das
alles zusammen das ist eine masse das so
wichtig ist hierbei dass der teig nicht
zu flüssig wird
ihr seht man braucht keine
küchenmaschine
warum brauche ich keine küchenmaschine
warum weil ich ein mann bin
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich den teig haben jetzt
zu einer homogenen masse verrührt ich
bin jetzt fix und fertig und jetzt kommt
eigentlich der schwierige teil und alle
zu mir zu nehmen
die musik ein blenden sollte dann jetzt
kommt der schwierige teil der
schwierigste teil von allen
und zwar habe ich hier ein bug rahmen so
einen deutschen bank kamen aus deutschen
edelstahl
was war jetzt im bug rahmen wir
versuchen jetzt den bug rahmen zusammen
zu bekommen und zwar hat es geht es ganz
ganz einfach und zwar hatten back haben
immer zwei lange teile und zwei kurze
teile und ich habe hier zwei lange und
zwei kurze teile und jetzt tut mir immer
die zwei langen und die zwei kurzen
teile zusammen stecken wie immer kurz zu
kurz und lang zu lang ist es richtig so
und dann lange style hier rein
[Musik]
hier stimmt was nicht
wahnsinn hat es gesehen wahnsinn oder
ich gehe damit auf tour demnächst und
zwar wenn man backen kann man zusammen
so jetzt haben diesen tollen tollen back
rahmen hier und jetzt haben wir hier die
dauer back folie und das spezial blech
ist immer das spezial blech machten
dauer vakuole drauf und dann den park
rahmen findet das alles mit seid ihr da
auch nicht okay und jetzt mache ich
einmal singen trägt uns war es kann sein
dass der teig etwas zu flüssig ist nein
ist er nicht aber trotzdem egal aber für
die leute wohnten
trotzdem wenn ihr das backblech zb nicht
habe und derzeit öfters mal ausläuft
kann verschiedene gründe haben fragt
einfach nicht ich hab keine ahnung was
ich da mache gibt es einen trick und
zwar nimmt man hier klammern
ihr kennt diese klammern und jetzt tue
ich diesen bug rahmen einschlagen
und zwar einmal hier
[Musik]
einmal hier einmal hier und einmal hier
ist toll an der ganzen geschichte ist de
facto die muss nicht wegschmeißen auch
wieder günstiger
und das ist nur ein trick ihr müsst sie
machen ihr kreuz machen
ich habe jetzt gemacht wahnsinn oder
wahnsinn jetzt nehme ich diesen tag hier
natürlich ist einfach ein wahnsinn oder
so und dann nämlich noch ein silikon
teilhaber und tut es noch kein schreiben
dass man sieht wie sorgfältig das macht
doch das geht nur im silicon valley
ich las nichts übrig warum er hat noch
kein krieg mitgemacht so dann habe ich
das rein gemacht
jetzt gibt es einen ganz ganz coolen
tricks und zwar damit er damit ich
weniger energie braucht damit er noch
schneller fertig mache ich den boden
einfach breiter und zwar sich
auseinander sagt ich habe auch selber
gezogen dass weiterhin wahnsinn
es ist ein rechteck noch ein bisschen
noch ein bisschen ich meine das
quadratische studiert also der ist
richtig und jetzt kommen einfach bei 190
grad 30 minuten in den backofen in den
vorgeheizten backofen also backofen
vorheizen warum machen wir das
warum damit der kuchen schön warm hat
und dann kriegt dann ein schock steil
und dann läuft auch nicht aus wahnsinn
oder weiß ich das weil ich schon mal
einige bugs angeschaut hat
zwischenzeitlich ist der kuchen schon
fertig und ich hole mal raus
so und und zwar so sieht es aus ihr seht
er hat ein bisschen der werbung und ich
möchte dir eine schöne glatte oberfläche
machen also tue ich denn den kuchen
stürzen hat ein kleines bisschen
seitlichen bauch und münchen jetzt
stürze dann drückt sind nach unten dann
ist der bauch weg deswegen schlafe ich
nachts immer auf bauch wenn ich morgens
nicht aufstehen ist alles flacht
wahnsinn oder so jetzt machen wir
folgendes jetzt immer dieses port messer
nehmen wir dieses deutsche tatmesser und
tone vom rand lösen machen auch dass die
aua aua macht es nicht zu hause nach ich
empfehle euch nochmal dass sie die
nadeln dienen ihm die dinger da aus was
sind es egal was ist da klammern genau
nicht aus kunststoff ganz ganz wichtig
machen es zu hause nicht nach das kann
die mod sei seit auch wenn es egal ist
weil das studium oder ist aber trotzdem
edelstahl hk mund nehmen so jetzt habe
ich die kuchen vom vom bug rahmen gelöst
so da stimmt irgendwas nicht haben wir
aliens zu hause und mir komisch steht
noch nicht richtig jetzt ziemlich es
auseinander
zack zack so sieht's aus wahnsinn oder
habt ihr schon mal so etwas gesehen hat
noch nie gesehen so und jetzt zumindest
ganze stürzen und zwar tode stürzen
wir unterstützen aber hiermit hiermit
stürzt sich den kuchen
jetzt müssen wir überlegen dass er sich
einfach das ist jetzt physikalisch nicht
sehr einfach aber ich kriege das hin und
zwar mache ich das so jetzt habe ich ihn
gestürzt jetzt ein problem und es fehlt
noch der hand kam es zu mir dass abkühlt
er überschrieben
wir haben jetzt auch gelöst
das backblech ist jetzt auch weg was man
als nächstes wir entfernen die folie und
zwar das war ganz ganz vorsichtig es ist
wie beim epilieren oder methan ist auch
schnell machen da plötzlich w wahnsinn
oder so ihr seht jetzt habe ich eine
schöne flache oberfläche und lassen uns
zu liegen was merz als trick noch machen
das ist ein besonderer trick von mir
betont kuchen
jetzt habe ich falsch gemacht
macht nichts mache jetzt so damals nicht
doch ich mache das so nicht machst doch
nicht ich mache das tuch darüber warum
damit der kuchen nicht austrocknet und
schön sachlich bleibt erstklassig
irgendwer so eine stunde liegen in der
zwischenzeit geht die kids abholen die
elf vom kindergarten gesamtjahr von der
schule weil die serie noch eine
baustelle und nachher den kids und macht
den kuchen für die schwierige mutter
fertigte die schwiegermutter fertig
genau wird lustig wir sehen uns in einer
stunde wieder
zunächst gab es einen gefallen ich
glaube ich was falsch gemacht
jetzt will noch mal zurückgekommen es
macht keinen sinn da es macht keinen
sinn an kuchen auf dem gitter zu haben
aber währenddessen noch hier eine
totenrede zu haben das heißt ich muss
den kuchen vom toten retter auf sub gilt
wieder abschieben
also abschieben das ding wehrt sich
irgendwo erkennen dass deswegen machen
wir das anders ich machen frick und zwar
nehme ich einfach nichts zur hand hat
nämlich das in die hand
da gehe ich jetzt runter und macht es
lieber nicht warum
was kommt jetzt machen ich weiß dass ich
jetzt mache ich mache das so so
[Applaus]
wahnsinn
habt ihr gesehen man muss nur sich nur
ein bisschen anstrengend bis mitdenken
und das funktioniert ist auch ganz von
alleine dank qualität marius ich geh
jetzt tickets abholen wahnsinns ding
jetzt soll das so abdecken
habt ihr euch gemerkt warum ist abdecke
damit sie nicht austrocknen richtig
mache ich richtig also ist gleich
schnell
so jetzt hab ich sah mir abgeholt und
die ella auch muss sie da vom
kindergarten unserer schule abholen wenn
man kann die kinder nicht auslassen
musste dann wieder zurückholen so und
jetzt gemacht erfahrung ist drauf und
ich bin die samira mit meinem backen ja
schon mir zusammen gebacken
ich versuche das backen mit meinen
kindern mit dass amira zusammen ihre
motorischen fähigkeiten zu entwickeln
und oder richtig falsch artikuliert
haben wie kann ich das ruhig sagen dann
dann dann spreche schneller sagte cantz
rechner
ok auf jeden fall was machen wir jetzt
haben den tortenboden gebacken was soll
ich jetzt machen ist wir keine
trockenboden in zwei hälften und machen
richtig coole im marmeladen krähen und
zwar ist die torte hatte um einige
morgen geburtstag und du magst die oma
richtig und was magst du noch um am
meisten
ich möchte mir genau wir mögen alles und
aroma und die oma zahlt auch unser haus
richtig
nein ok auf jeden fall da nicht
irgendwie mit den trockenen boden hier
raus hier runter sagt der stoff schon
richtig fest geworden und tun ihnen dann
die torten säge in zwei hälften stein
ist zeigt wie das geht haben wir die
höchste ganz kurz
der papa weiss ist noch nicht so ganz
genau
hältst du halt den taten wurden 14
dortmund ja aber ich habe auch angst
wasser kaputtgeht haben wissenschaft ist
okay wir haben es geschafft zusammen
gepfiffen ich alles geschafft haben auch
nicht so jetzt haben den tortenboden
hier und tun die hier und jetzt nehmen
wir hier
ich habe eine richtig coole marmelade
das ist so eine erdbeer marmelade und
die schon jetzt grausam mir auch nicht
erklären
das ist hier mehr und anderes als er per
schwarz-weiße das ja ja so lässt schon
im boden schön damit einschmieren und
machen den kuchen so richtig saftig okay
nicht zu viel nicht zu wenig genau das
was sachsen
es ist ja auch komisch möglich zu
erledigen aber von ihr ja hast du mich
gerade bedeuten hast du nicht gekränkt
[Musik]
dass amira zusammen eingestrichen
rechtsschutz hat sich merklich kurz ok
jetzt sehen wir dass alles eingestrichen
träume muss auf wenn man muss den
arbeitsplatz immer sauber halten richtig
okay wir das machen das ist jetzt kein
zimmer aufgeräumt wichtig ja jetzt immer
den tortenboden und machen den drauf
achten rang recht genau so und jetzt
macht dieser mir hatte ich etwas richtig
cooles und zwar noch meine torten creme
um die torte etwas geschmack
einzuhauchen okay okay für die toten
creme brauchen wir 175 gramm
kinder brauchen wir nicht brauchen nur
die hälfte die hälfte von 150 sind wie
viel verpackung genau ja stimmen die
halt also die hälfte von 170 g data ist
ein halbes
100 g schlagsahne ein teelöffel vanille
extrakt 25 gramm puderzucker und zwei
teelöffel sommer fallen
das nehme jetzt alles zusammen mit dass
amira und tun bis in eine schwarze
richtig jetzt sind wir hier sallys
agenten koffer und werden hier jetzt
diesen staatlich zu benutzen wenn wir
ihn auf kriegen hier geht der koffer auf
so das ding hier
wir vertrauen dir noch einen schneebesen
988 die eine m und eine sorge treibt es
in rift oben erschweren das muss man
dreht sich mit seinem hingekriegt so
okay jetzt zum alle zutaten genau aber
nur die hälfte verpackt nur die hälfte
genau die hälfte sind wie viel prozent
genau die halbe packung die halle packen
und hiervon auch wir machen das alles
per augenmaß wir sind schon viele profis
hält gereist
[Musik]
und dann tun wie puderzucker auch mit
rein und dann zwei teelöffel seiner
partei
[Musik]
ein extrakt aber alles drin
ok jetzt ja hältst du dich südwest
das problem ist folgendes die creme wird
noch nicht stark genug ist nicht mehr
einfach noch mal ein bisschen sand haben
und zwar nochmal teelöffel sagt ja zu
wie konsens sei wir nehmen jetzt überall
die doppelte menge
ja also hab ich gemerkt wie creme ist zu
wenig ja und jetzt über die doppelte
nämlich nochmal konzentrat genannt spaß
gemacht ja hat wahnsinnig spaß gemacht
ich freue mich so richtig es ist nur
einfach die doppelte mehr hinnehmen 175
gramm philadelphia dann immer die
doppelte menge an sahne und dann immer
dass man den extrakt reicht schon wenn
man einfach mal so apart und zwar
nochmal zwei löffel also insgesamt habe
ich fünf löffel seiner partei
reingemacht 200 meter schlagsahne und
175 gramm philadelphia-frischkäse
probier's mal
nicht so gut falco tja ja also meine
wahnsinnige skills das kann nur der papa
habe ich recht so jetzt haben wir die
creme fertig gerührt und jetzt räumen
wir ganz kurz zusammen auf das man
erstmal weg machen ob alles da
bis gleich und jetzt zum an die torte
einfach mal einstreichen und die krebse
eigentlich super wie ich nicht so ganz
verwaist weil ich zu dir aleks zeit
wahrscheinlich reingemacht hat das heißt
ich bin auch ohne daniel extrakt zb
arbeiten oder lassen schwingt nicht
klasse
das tun sie einstreichen mit einer
[Musik]
palette richtig so und wir machen das
genau wie beim mauer richtig daten in
wiesbaden das theater
so jetzt mal folgendes jetzt habe die
partie eingestrichen
ja und jetzt wird es gleich hart also
auch der partner plötzlich gleich
verhärten
die sahen ihn lässt sich gleichwohl
hätten deswegen macht sanierung
folgendes wir tun jetzt schon mal wird
uns jetzt schon mal die karte garnieren
ok und zwar ist so geplant ich tue ist
verziert mit dem iran zusammen mit
himbeeren zusammen und dann kommt hier
so die schleiferei so als geschenk also
wohl jetzt erstmal nicht richtig ich
habe jetzt 500 g himbeeren und wann
richtig teuer ich wusste nicht ob ich
jetzt die himberg kaufen solle die
goldkette von puma von thomas sabo wie
das heißt aber für die omas wert genau
richtig und ich übrig supermarkt in der
schmuckabteilung weil die so teuer sind
aber jetzt machen sie drauf für die oma
einfach schön so ganz nah nebeneinander
okay ja ja ganz schnell ganz schnell
sowie die chinesin
[Musik]
also wir haben fehler gemacht wir haben
mehr gebraucht als wir eigentlich vorhin
angegeben haben insgesamt neun mal 125
gramm hindern gebracht wahnsinn ich
hätte auch nicht gedacht und anderen
fehlt aber noch gemacht und zwar sehr
jetzt hier die torte ich hätte die
schleife dazwischen legen soll sie
besser aus jetzt versuche ich gerade das
ding noch zu retten indem ich alles ein
bisschen rüberschieben und seitenkanal
es auch essen und dann in der mitte das
gleiche eigentlich war es kein fehler
das war geplant und ich richtig zu
stimmen
[Musik]
jetzt soll aber fürs geschenkpapier sein
aber wir haben es noch gerettet und
jetzt machen wir das es aussieht das in
geschenkpapier aussieht wenn wir jetzt
modelliert schokolade und die modelle
schokolade tour mit dem iran jetzt
ausrollen und jetzt holt samira die
silikon matte und nicht zu sagen die
torte etwas kühl stellen
ich habe jetzt 100 gramm modelliert
schokolade gegeben wenn ich bin einfach
himbeeren schokolade sahne das passt
alles zusammen und jetzt immer diese
diese 100 gramm und die muss man jetzt
nur handwarm vertreten und die schläuche
in der mitte von der torte ist
eigentlich genauso breit wie das lineal
das heißt ich kann es bisher gut
einstellen auf genau diese größe so
schafft sofort natürlich hier das ding
fixieren so und es tut mir jetzt
ausschreiben und ausrollen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
denn wenn man erst mal hierher anatomie
das erste mal aussteigen
[Musik]
wir tun das einsprühen okay weg damit
von richtig coolen gold effekt hat
natürlich diese zwar einspringen
so jetzt haben wir den haben wir die
modelle schokolade haben wir jetzt in
gold sprechers offen
und jetzt wartet bis es trocknet oder
wir warten bis es trocknet und der
zwischenzeit lasse ich das trocknen und
mache solange die anderen auch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die serie hat beim beim lackieren
natürlich was darunter gelegt ich habe
es nicht gemacht
deswegen mache ich jetzt hier einfach
gut sauber das ist einfach mit wasser
eigentlich leicht wegzukriegen jetzt
immer so weit mit der samira es jetzt
schon mal hier
die torte hin und es war richtig cool
ich schleife drauf okay die immer eine
schleife haus kinder extra ist wenn was
passiert oder nicht sagte dass das meine
ich ja nein schafft es nicht stimmt
datum bist du jetzt ähnliche abschneiden
und dann machen wir nochmal eins und
dann das machen erklärt
[Musik]
normal hätte es besser gemacht ich weiß
es aber
aber kann das auch gut machen
[Musik]
und jetzt machen die schleife und zwar
machen die schleife wie jetzt machen wir
mal so rein dann macht ihr zur hälfte so
aber papa joe's schau mal das zeit
auseinander der karte dort noch wehrheim
machen wo sie hatten mit gleicher
freiheit verstanden muss man dann gibt's
noch zusammen dann geht es gar nicht
mehr so was macht man einst so samir
rechts zwischen schloss kind man merkt
dass du meine tochter bist so was machen
wir jetzt so hin
und jetzt lassen wir es kurz im
kühlschrank trockenen die module ihr
schokolade wird nämlich jetzt fest und
ein zimmer es nachher einfach raus oder
haben wir eine richtig coole trotzdem
okay so richtig schlau bist echt
schaffen
[Musik]
okay wir haben es geschafft die torte
ist jetzt ein bisschen gekühlt und die
bekommt jetzt morgen die schwierige
mutter schwiegermutter und die oma ich
hätte niemals gedacht dass die erste
motiv torte als man kann es ja motiv
torte nennen dich gebacken habe in
meinem leben für meine schwiegermutter
ist wahnsinn
richtig cool wie recht stolz auf dich
hat meist oma freut sich gut hausarrest
auch aus resten alle hausarrest wir
gehen jetzt nach
wir gehen jetzt wenn wir zehn heissesten
zusammen also ok du bleibst zu hause
gegen eis essen okay okay gut also
morgen haben wir freuen uns auch richtig
auf die oma und ich hoffe die torte wird
dir gefallen und das hat mir echt cool
ok ich hoffe ihr schreiben diesmal
wieder ein beim murats fünf minuten das
ist mir jedes mal eine freude für euch
ein video zu machen meine frau ist
gerade auf dem bau und dem xcom mehrere
videos von mir und kommentiert hättet
mich nicht ich mich wenn mir egal
macht's gut macht's besser wir sehen uns
abonniert den kanal macht's gut
aber jetzt mal ja
[Musik]